MALE SPEAKER 1:
Ladies and gentlemen,
give a big hand for John Waters.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Keep it going.
The man came a long way.
JOHN WATERS: Has anybody
in this room ever actually
read from a book?
I mean, it seems like at
Google, everybody would read it,
you know, on Kindle
and all that.
OK.
MALE SPEAKER 1: This is
a relic from yesteryear.
It's called a book.
You open it up.
There are pages-- very similar
to the things that you scroll.
JOHN WATERS: I don't care
how anybody reads it,
as long as they read it.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Well, let's talk
a little bit about your book.
This is called "Carsick."
Two years ago, John
decided to hitchhike
across the country from
his apartment in Baltimore
to his other apartment
in San Francisco.
And so basically
what you have is,
you've got this
into three parts.
You've got "The Best
That Could Happen,"
which is a fictitious account
of the best possible outcome,
which kind of, to me felt
like an X-rated "Pee-wee's Big
Adventure."
JOHN WATERS: That's a good one.
MALE SPEAKER 1:
And then you've got
"The Worst That
Could Happen," which
is kind of a very dark
road horror story.
And then the third chapter
is "The Real Thing,"
which is what actually happened.
JOHN WATERS: Which
is optimistic.
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
JOHN WATERS: Compared.
MALE SPEAKER 1: So
I have to admit,
I was kind of relieved by
the time I got to that part.
JOHN WATERS: My
assistant said, I
couldn't tell the difference
between the good and the bad
- they were all horrible to me.
What you think is good--
MALE SPEAKER 1: Yeah,
I was thinking that.
I was like, the best outcome
felt like somebody else's worst
outcome.
JOHN WATERS: Yeah, well.
MALE SPEAKER 1: So,
did a lot of people
try to talk you out
of this adventure?
JOHN WATERS: As it got closer,
all the people that work for me
were horrified about it.
Yeah, and I was surprised.
Even my friends
that are criminals
tried to talk me out of it.
I thought they'd be for it.
The younger the person, the more
they sort of liked the idea.
And all the younger
they were people
that had never hitchhiked.
Because no one hitchhikes.
The whole way across the country
I saw one other hitchhiker.
And I told my driver,
don't pick him up.
I know, I know, but
you know, you've
got to be selfish when
you're hitchhiking.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Well yeah,
it's like, hitchhiking
is that even a thing anymore?
JOHN WATERS: I had
a sign, always,
and people thought I was so
stupid of a homeless person
that instead of standing
at a red light and begging,
I was down on the freeway.
Like, who could pull over
and give you a quarter?
When they see you with a sign
now, that's what they think.
They don't even know
about hitchhiking.
A child once-- this was another
time I was hitchhiking when
I was, trainer wheels,
you know, training
to do this-- in Provincetown
a family picked me up
and the little kid was
in the car staring at me.
He said, Dad, why is
this man in the car?
Why did you stop?
Who is he?
It was really embarrassing,
because they didn't even
know what hitchhiking was.
MALE SPEAKER 2: It's like,
when was his last film?
The kid.
JOHN WATERS: Well, no, I don't
know if they recognized me.
I forget if they
asked me what I do.
I never bring it up.
MALE SPEAKER 2: So you
did a series of training
runs in Provincetown.
JOHN WATERS: Well, I used
to have hitchhiking dates.
It was really a great come on.
Do you want to go hitchhiking
with me to the beach?
Because this one beach,
you have to have a sticker
or live in that beach.
And I didn't have one, so
the only way you could go
was hitchhike.
And it was a 15 mile ride.
It was not that hard
if you didn't make it.
And in Provincetown,
to be honest.
People did recognize me.
So it was like hailing
a limousine [INAUDIBLE].
But coming back wasn't.
Coming back wasn't.
And I did hitchhike
with Patty Hearst once.
And I always met the
person, get in the back.
I get in the front.
And the man was looking
over like he recognized me.
And then he said,
are you John Waters?
I said, yeah, and
that's Patricia Hearst.
And he looked in
the rearview mirror.
And she said, he made me do it.
[LAUGHTER]
And later, her husband
was really pissed off.
He said, hasn't she had
enough trouble, John?
And it's true.
I said to her, look, but have I?
No.
MALE SPEAKER 2: So
as somebody who's
done the whole gamut of
entertainment things--
books, movies, acting,
voiceover, everything
you can imagine,
this guy's done it--
what was the impetus
for this type of book?
JOHN WATERS: An adventure.
You know, my life.
It was my mid-life crisis.
I don't want to buy a
convertible I won't even
get in a convertible at my age.
But I needed an adventure.
My life was so planned,
so controlled, so safe.
Can I give all that up
and see what happens?
And I did.
And I always felt my
street cred would go up.
I was impressed--
at 66 years old,
I hitchhiked across the country.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Yeah, come on!
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN WATERS: Just by
myself, with no backup.
And there were horrible
days, you know,
when I'm sitting there,
waiting 10 hours for a car.
And it was so hot one day--
I would call my assistant
and whine all the time.
Just say, I have to
drink my own urine, now.
And stuff like that.
Because I would
just be stuck there.
And I would run out of water.
I didn't do that, but-- I
was like "Pink Flamingos."
I was living in camp
station laboratories
some days, which
was really humbling.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Well, you didn't
tell your mother before going,
and then she found out later.
Is she shocked by anything
you do at this point?
JOHN WATERS: Well,
my assistant Susan
said that she wasn't,
because you beat her down
into submission.
But my mother always said that
she wasn't shocked by something
until then I'd say,
OK, well then, here.
And then she'd say, why would
you do something like that?
So that wasn't completely true.
My mom, unfortunately,
died this year.
But she had a great
life, and everything.
But she did say stuff
like, with my movies,
what's this one about?
And I'd say, sex addiction.
She'd go, oh.
Maybe we'll die first.
[LAUGHTER]
The only good thing about
my mother passing away
is that she won't
read this book.
Because there are parts in it
that would really kill her,
right?
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER 1:
Well, yeah, I mean
this felt like this kind
of goes back to your roots,
your really trashy roots
especially the first two
novellas.
How do you--
JOHN WATERS: Well, I did think
up the best and the worst.
They are extreme, to me.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Well,
a lot of people,
say some of the more
housewife type of characters
that you met recognize you from,
they know you from "Hairspray."
JOHN WATERS: Housewife is a
politically incorrect word.
Is there such a thing
as a housewife anymore?
Like, sitting around,
baking pies in an apron?
I don't even know about--
MALE SPEAKER 1: All
right, old broads.
JOHN WATERS: Yeah-- no!
Working moms.
No-- I don't know.
But the people that
picked me up in real life
are the opposite of
the first two chapters.
They were probably fairly
normal but really sweet,
really progressive
in how they thought,
completely different
than what-- I really
hate that expression, "flyover
people," because these were
what is snottily referred to.
But to me, they were
more liberal and smart
than a lot of people
I know in Manhattan
and L.A. They were
open to stuff.
They just didn't
bullshit, you know?
They hated freeloaders.
That's the main thing.
And the most interesting thing--
I don't think a gay person
picked me up, which was--
but the straight men,
the straight men all talked
about how much they love
their wife and how smart
she was and everything.
It gave heterosexuality
such a good name.
They have to feel good
about themselves, too.
MALE SPEAKER 2: You want to--?
We'll switch.
JOHN WATERS: So that
was kind of amazing.
And so all the women I
know in New York say,
I can never meet a straight man.
Go hitchhike on Route 70.
The problem is they're
all happily married.
You have to move to the town
early and then find one first.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Not to poke
too many holes in that,
but do you think some of them
were like, I-- I'm married.
I have a wife.
JOHN WATERS: No, no, no.
And the gay thing, one guy
was a total Republican,
and he said to me, you
know, I'm for Obama,
now that he said he
was for gay marriage.
When he said he was evolving,
that was such bullshit.
So [INAUDIBLE] not always
predictable about how
they felt about stuff.
MALE SPEAKER 1: I guess if
they're going to pick you up.
If they're picking
up a hitchhiker,
they're probably
pretty open people.
JOHN WATERS: I don't know.
I got a ride in a
90,000 pound truck,
and I never felt gayer
climbing up those steps
to get in that truck.
I felt like a complete fool.
You know, this is like
a porn joke, right?
The guy couldn't
have been nicer.
He was great.
It's what gay bears
wish they were.
He was a straight bear.
But he doesn't even
know about bears.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Can you explain
for some of the mainstream
kind of straight people, the
fascination with truckers?
JOHN WATERS: I-- I
didn't say I had--
MALE SPEAKER 2: No, not yours.
MALE SPEAKER 1: I
read the first--
JOHN WATERS: There's
not that many people
you get a ride with.
Oh, you mean the porn
fantasy of truckers?
Well, truck stops.
I wrote a great
best-case scenario
of an illegal truck stop.
And I do have a real trucker
friend who's out of his mind.
I'd be scared for
him to pick me up.
He says he carries fake
piss for the drug tests.
He dumps things on people's
lawn if they weight too much.
He picks up runaway girls
and has sex with them.
He jerks off in a sock.
And he says, want
me to send it you?
I said, no!
I don't want you
to send it to me.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER 1: All right.
JOHN WATERS: Does that help?
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER 1: I'm fascinated.
MALE SPEAKER 2:
That's the real part.
JOHN WATERS: No, that's not
the real part-- in the book,
I don't have-- oh,
the guy is real.
The real trucker is real, yeah.
God, no, yeah.
The criminal one, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Well, there's
a line early in the book,
and you say this a
couple times, where
you believe in the basic
goodness in people.
Was that sort of like
your thesis statement,
or was that what you set
out to prove, or was it--
JOHN WATERS: That's about
as spiritual as I get.
I do believe in the
basic goodness of people.
There are people that are
born wired wrong, though, yes.
But I have faith in people.
I taught in prison.
I can get along with
all kinds of people.
I'm not scared of people.
And I am a good listener.
And people will
tell me anything.
I mean, I've said this before.
I get on an airplane and a
stranger will turn next to me
and say, my entire family
fuck me in an Easter basket
on Easter morning.
Why do they tell me that?
Because I'll understand.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER 1: I
mean, isn't it so much
more interesting to
talk to those people
than, you know-- us?
JOHN WATERS: No.
No, because-- I never understand
people say they're bored.
Well, walk outside
and look at people.
I'm never bored.
That's the one thing I
never am, because I'm
interested in human behavior.
And the most that I
made the movies about
and that I wrote
about are people
that think they're normal
but, to me, are really insane.
Because most of
the people I know
in New York who think
they're insane are actually
kind of normal.
So it's always weird
how people conceive
of themselves and
their own beliefs.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Did you find
any of that on the road-- people
that were more-- Were
people more insane
than you thought they
would be, or less?
JOHN WATERS: They were neither.
I don't know that I
thought they'd be insane.
The people were-- I did
not get a scary ride.
I didn't even get one
that was a bad driver.
I got 21 rides, it took.
I got a coal miner--
MALE SPEAKER 1: That
sounds surprisingly low.
JOHN WATERS: Well, one
big character in the book,
the Karate Kid--
MALE SPEAKER 1: The Corvette--
JOHN WATERS: Corvette Kid.
He was a Republican
elected official
in Millersville, Maryland.
And he picked me up
in the pouring rain
when he was going to get
his lunch at the Subway.
He didn't know who I was,
even after I told him.
We just kept talking.
He drove me all the way to Ohio.
His parents were,
like, horrified.
Where is he?
And looked up John Waters.
It's not good if you Google me.
It's bad.
[LAUGHTER]
Friends with one of the
Manson family, you know?
Like, oh, great!
My kid's with him.
And then he went back.
And then he kept texting
me the whole time.
And then he said,
I'm coming to get ya.
And drove 48 hours straight
at 80 miles an hour
and caught up with me in Denver.
So he was great.
We just had a--
MALE SPEAKER 1: And you
met him in Baltimore.
JOHN WATERS: I didn't meet
him-- oh, afterwards I met him.
But I didn't know him.
MALE SPEAKER 1: But that's
where he first picked you up--
JOHN WATERS: We met
in Millersville.
It was the third ride.
Which is about an hour
outside of Baltimore.
I didn't even know
what Millersville was.
MALE SPEAKER 1: It kind of
reminded me of the scene
in "The Jerk" when you
were first getting started.
I think with the first
guy took you, like,
down the block or something.
JOHN WATERS: Well,
the first ride
was a great, African-American
Tracy Turnblad kind of gal
with her baby, going to daycare.
And she said, I can't
take you any further,
because I have to go to work.
But she was lovely.
And it was pouring rain.
That's the thing.
I did a lot of
research to find out
the most moderate
temperature on Route 70,
which was this week in May,
but the thing I didn't look up
is, it rains every day.
So the first two days,
I stood there literally
in pouring down rain.
I thought, I'm
gonna kill myself.
What book is this?
MALE SPEAKER 1: So you
never got sick or anything?
JOHN WATERS: No.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Wow.
JOHN WATERS: Well,
I mean-- mentally.
MALE SPEAKER 2: That
happened a long time ago.
JOHN WATERS: Oh, car sick.
My friend told me
the other day--
MALE SPEAKER 2: Just
lower it a little.
JOHN WATERS: OK.
He said, you know, when I was
a child, I always got carsick.
And you take the
jacket off, look,
and it's the color
of the exact medicine
I had to take as a child.
I think that was accidental.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Did
you learn about--
what did you learn to be the
best techniques to hitchhike?
JOHN WATERS: With the
sign, humor didn't work.
I had one that said,
I'm not psycho.
People laughed but
they didn't pick me up.
"Writing a book"
really didn't work,
because then they'd
think, about what?
And they want their
own private life.
Something that didn't
work if I was starting out
in Baltimore instead
of San Francisco.
It's like a joke.
You had to have a possible
end, so "End of Route 70," even
though it was 2000 miles
or something, at least
meant, please, take me a long
way, but it was possible.
So it had to be.
And at the end of
every day, I always
never wanted to
hitchhike at night.
So the trick was where
you get dropped off.
So at the end of
every day, I wanted
a place that had a hotel.
So I made this sign
that said, "Next motel."
I felt like a hooker, so I
just changed it to "hotel"
even though there
weren't any hotels.
But it seemed much less tawdry.
MALE SPEAKER 1: In "The
Best That Could Happen,"
you were immediately given--
what was it-- $5 million
by a drug dealer to make
your next film, "Fruitcake."
That's a movie that's--
JOHN WATERS: That
is a movie I've
been trying to make
that didn't get made.
So who knows?
Maybe someone will read the
book and send me the check.
They gave it to me
in cash and said
that I would never have
notes, not to worry.
You know, it was like a joke of
the best possible producer you
could ever get. "We really
don't care if it makes money,
but here."
And they own a criminally
corrupt FedEx office
that only deals in their drugs.
And the people that
work there look
like they escaped from
a Whole Foods jail.
You know that look.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Are we ever
going to see that film?
What's the state of low-budget,
independent film right now?
JOHN WATERS: Oh, it's bad.
I mean TV is better now.
More people see it.
So no, the independent film
world that I know is no longer.
They're looking for
me when I was 20.
They'd like me to make a film
with the budget of "Polyester,"
certainly.
MALE SPEAKER 1:
Which was how much?
JOHN WATERS: $300,000.
Which today would be
probably $600,000.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Would you ever
consider doing a Kickstarter?
JOHN WATERS: No, public
begging, I can't, I can't.
You know, I own--
MALE SPEAKER 1:
Says the guy who--
JOHN WATERS: I own three homes.
No, but I own three homes.
As much as I wanted to
go to Occupy Baltimore,
I can't be that hypocritical.
And I don't hate all rich.
There's asshole poor
people I know, too.
There's good and
bad in both, really.
But I liked Occupy Baltimore.
I get why they're going
there, the same way I
want to Black Panther riots
in the '60s-- to have sex,
to take drugs.
I understand the
tribal fun of a riot.
MALE SPEAKER 2: In the fictional
part, you witnessed-- sorry,
you referenced-- sorry, I just
got off a plane from Russia,
so I'm a little stupid.
I'm also stupid in real life.
But you reference the
soundtracks a lot.
JOHN WATERS: Yeah, the
book has a playlist
at the end, which you can go
and look up online and play
all the music.
And it's-- oddly enough, all
music about hitchhiking is
country music.
Almost all of it.
Except for the famous
"Hitchhike" song
by Marvin Gaye.
But I found some great ones,
really obscure hitchhike
records.
I always have a soundtrack
to everything I do.
Even when I'm walking down the
street, kind of in my head,
I need a soundtrack.
MALE SPEAKER 2: [SINGING] Going
to Google, going to Google,
what the hell is this?
JOHN WATERS: Is there
a Google Dance yet?
There should be.
MALE SPEAKER 2:
Oh, yeah, totally.
Nobody goes, but--
Everybody [INAUDIBLE]
with their computer and works.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Oh, you mean,
like, a dance-- function or--
JOHN WATERS: Yeah,
like the twist.
MALE SPEAKER 1:
Everybody's doing it.
You know, there's a gimmick
dance, like the Google.
You should make one.
No, that's the hacker.
You know, I always thought,
I want a hacker boyfriend
because they're always
home up there in that room
with the door closed, waiting
to put the food outside
while they're shutting
down the government
of foreign countries.
MALE SPEAKER 2:
There's some people
doing a dance over there.
You'll see everybody
doing that during the day.
MALE SPEAKER 1: It's a
very anti-social dance.
MALE SPEAKER 2: What were people
listening to in their cars?
JOHN WATERS: Almost
never was the radio on.
When I hitchhiked, when you
pick up-- they want to talk.
So, I don't remember
ever the radio
being on on one car
that ever picked me up.
With Here We Go Magic, a
rock group that picked me up
that I did not know, and they
accidentally picked me up,
they played my mix tape.
And they gave me
their tape, but I
played that alone
in the motel, we
didn't play it in front of them.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Were
they a good band?
JOHN WATERS: Yeah,
they are good, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER 1: OK, because
I was really liking them
in the book and I was
like, it would be terrible
if they were--
JOHN WATERS: Well, I
wouldn't have minded a ride
with a terrible band, either.
I would've gotten
in, believe me.
I wasn't, like, [INAUDIBLE],
all right, let me hear a hit,
first.
[LAUGHTER]
No thanks.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Oh,
oh it's Nickelback.
Keep driving.
Spoiler alert-- in "The
Worst That Could Happen,"
you actually describe your
own death at the hands of a--
JOHN WATERS: Well, don't
tell them the whole thing.
MALE SPEAKER 1: OK, OK.
Can I tell--
JOHN WATERS: Well, if
you think of the worst
and you're
hitchhiking, obviously,
you get killed, yeah.
In Las Vegas.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Can I
tell them about the movie
that's playing in Hell?
JOHN WATERS: Oh, no.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Aww,
all right, all right.
JOHN WATERS: But I do
imagine the person that
kills me-- always said that
most serial killers, their type
isn't a 66-year-old
film cult director.
But in the book, there is one.
Who's only looking for that.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Is it, like,
Leonard Maltin or something?
JOHN WATERS: [CHUCKLES] No.
MALE SPEAKER 1: What's the most
shockingly mainstream thing
that you're a fan of?
JOHN WATERS: That's a good one.
I don't know.
Oh, um.
Hmm.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Shoes
JOHN WATERS: 3D.
I'm for all 3D.
I like 3D, but I went
to see things like,
what was the one with
the big tits in--
MALE SPEAKER 1: Oh, "Piranha?"
JOHN WATERS: "Piranha 3DD,"
that was what it was called.
And I went, but last
night of the run,
and I was alone in
a theater watching
"Piranha 3DD" with 3D glasses
on, looking like such a fool.
I was the only person in the
theater for the 10 o'clock show
the last day.
But I didn't miss it.
I'm also a big fan of all
"Final Destination" movies.
I love them.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Oh,
those are great, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Are
there going to be
any more hitchhiking
adventures in your future?
JOHN WATERS: I hope not.
If I miss a flight.
No, once I did it, I
don't have to do it again.
But you all should do it.
You should try hitchhiking.
I think it is a
little adventure,
you can do it on
your summer vacation,
and if you get murdered,
it's not my fault.
But you could get murdered
in a care accident.
I'm scared of staying at home.
If you never go
out either, that's
more dangerous than taking
a chance hitchhiking.
Because nothing new
will ever happen to you.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Do you
think if you had done--
would this have been easier
to do in the '70s than now
even if you weren't famous?
JOHN WATERS: In the
old days, the problem
was, there was so
many hitchhikers.
They were places-- New Haven
was a famous place where there
would be a hundred
hitchhikers there.
So it was better for that.
There was no competition.
But the younger you
are, the better chance
you have a ride,
certainly-- to get 'em.
And I was in the one truck stop.
I was talking to
the guy checking in,
and I said that really
truckers can't pick you up now,
because they have
two in the truck.
And this trucker who
was standing behind me
said, if you had a
vagina, they would.
Oh.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Oh, I
want to talk a little bit
about the Corvette Kid.
Do you still keep
in touch with him?
JOHN WATERS: I do.
He came to my Christmas party.
He's looking great, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Does
he really, does he
look like Justin Bieber?
JOHN WATERS: No, but I'm a
fan of Justin Bieber's, too.
Even more so now.
When he's Bizzle.
No, Bizzle's gonna
be his rap name.
That makes me really love him.
Bizzle.
I wanna hear his rhymes.
Oh, my God.
I love it when he's black.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER 2: So just
looking at your body of work,
it seems like
you're always busy.
Are you thinking forward
to your next thing
after you get
through this huge--
JOHN WATERS: Yeah, I got
next things, already.
I'm booked for the next year.
The spoken word show
called "This Filthy World"
I do all over the world.
I have a Christmas show, I've
got 20 in December coming up.
I'm having an art show at
Marianne Boesky Gallery
and one in London.
I have another
big project that I
can't announce
yet that's coming.
And maybe another one that
I'm writing this summer.
So, yeah, I got a job.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Where do you
find the time for all this?
JOHN WATERS: That's
a good question.
I'm highly organized.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Are you?
JOHN WATERS: Yeah.
Monday to Friday, I get
up every morning at 6 am.
I read all the newspapers.
I still read newspapers.
And then my job is every
morning to think up
something fucked up, and I've
gotta sell it in the afternoon.
Monday to Friday.
I drink one day a week.
So I'm a workaholic
five, an alcoholic one,
and the other day I take off.
And my shrink says, that
sounds like a good plan to me.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Is there one
sort of guiding book or film
that you are aiming towards,
that sets the bar for you
in everything you do?
JOHN WATERS: No, not really.
Because when I
grew up, certainly
Genet and Tennessee Williams and
all those kind of people which
I wrote about in my last
book, "Role Models," all
the people that
kind of gave me the,
I don't know, the courage to
try to do what I wanted to do.
So no, I think
those kind of things
happen to you when you're young.
Today, I love
Michel Houellebecq.
I love his novels.
I'm reading this one from
Norway, the six volume
memoir, "My Struggle,"
which is great, by the way.
So I like to read.
Yeah, that's what I
do for relaxation.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Do you write
your books in the same way
that you do your films?
JOHN WATERS: Yeah,
I write everything
on a special kind of legal pad
with big pens and scotch tape.
And then my assistant puts it in
the computer, the first draft.
And then I cut it up again.
Yeah, I do it the same way.
MALE SPEAKER 1: In longhand.
JOHN WATERS: In longhand.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Wow.
That's amazing.
It seems like there's a
lot of guys that do that.
JOHN WATERS: Doesn't
matter how you write it.
You could use your
head on a blackboard
as a human typewriter.
As long as you write
it, it doesn't matter.
Nobody asks at the end,
how did you do that book?
Never in my life
has anybody that's
ever paid me one penny ever
asked me if I went to school.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Did
you go to school?
JOHN WATERS: No.
I had trouble in school.
But I was lucky, I didn't
want to be a doctor.
I'm glad that I'm not a
doctor and no one asked.
MALE SPEAKER 2:
Well, you were at NYU
and then you got kicked out.
JOHN WATERS: Yeah, well
they weren't used to me.
Because I took acid every day
and just stole books and then
resold them in the
bookstore in the afternoon.
They should've thrown me out.
MALE SPEAKER 2: But
you were working.
It wasn't like you
weren't working.
You wanted--
JOHN WATERS: Well, I
didn't even come to class.
I just took drugs and went
to the movies every day.
But not "Potemkin," which
they showed us over and over.
But nowadays NYU is great.
I could go there.
You could make a snuff
film and get an A.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER 2: On that
note, we have a mic there
for audience questions.
So if you have a question, you
can just kind of circulate over
there and we'll call on you.
JOHN WATERS: Or you
can yell it out.
You don't have to do the full--
MALE SPEAKER 2: I think
they're doing that for audio.
JOHN WATERS: Oh, OK.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So I have your
Christmas record compilation.
JOHN WATERS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: It's a very
special place in my heart.
JOHN WATERS: Aww, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Can you
describe how you
chose all those songs,
where you found them?
JOHN WATERS: Well,
I always liked
weird novelty songs
and hillbilly records
and old rhythm and blues.
And so I just look for
every weird Christmas
carol I could find.
And the one song,
"I'm Fat Daddy,"
was the main black disc
jockey in Baltimore
where, in "Hairspray," I
joked they had "Negro Day."
They really did have that.
And he was the host of "Negro
Day," and that was his song.
"I'm Fat Daddy,
I'm Santa Claus."
And then the other song,
"Santa Claus Is A Black Man,"
I love that song.
And the governor of
Maryland, O'Malley,
when he was the mayor, turned
on the Christmas lights
of all of Baltimore downtown
with me and the mayor
and they played that as
the introduction, which
was great and very
fitting for Baltimore.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Anybody else?
MALE SPEAKER 2: Just real
quick as he gets up here.
Mark's from around Baltimore.
And he does this--
we're always wondering--
MALE SPEAKER 1: How do
you not have that accent?
JOHN WATERS: I think
I probably do have it.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Do the accent.
Listen.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Um, well--
let me try to do it again.
JOHN WATERS: Here's
every person answers
the phone in
Baltimore-- one minute.
MALE SPEAKER 1: My family and
I, we go to Ocean City, Maryland
every summer.
And there's this commercial for
this place called Purple Moose
Saloon, "The home of
hard rockin' Ocean City."
It's like everybody's mouth
seems like it's a small hole
and they're trying
to get words out of.
JOHN WATERS: In "Pink
Flamingos" I make fun of that.
I'm the narrator
in the beginning.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
John Travolta actually
did a pretty good job
in the remake of the--
JOHN WATERS: Yeah.
The Baltimore accent
is really grating.
Philadelphia's
very close, though.
It sounds similar.
All regional accents
can be grating,
unless you're in the
mafia-- except New York.
Then they kind of sound good.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Yeah, I
noticed they didn't-- none
of the people in "The
Wire", they were like, yeah,
don't talk like that.
Nobody's gonna
think you're cool.
JOHN WATERS: "The
Wire" is so great.
It's my favorite
television show ever.
And everybody down
there worked on it.
But that's a black-- that's
a different kind of Baltimore
accent.
MALE SPEAKER 2:
Beyond the ocean.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I've never actually
see any of your work,
but I did see you
on the Big Thing.
I did see an interview
on the Big Thing
and I was really
intrigued by that.
So where should I
start in the John
Waters oeuvre to maximize--
JOHN WATERS: Depends.
Do you want to go low or high?
I would say, "Female
Trouble" and "Serial Mom."
AUDIENCE: Say again?
JOHN WATERS: And "Serial Mom."
One was very early,
one was very late.
But I think they kind
of sum up everything.
MALE SPEAKER 1: On a
personal note, the first time
I saw "Female Trouble,"
I felt like it
was the first time I heard the
Sex Pistols, where I was, like,
laughing but I was also scared.
And my new roommate
showed it to me,
so then I was scared of him.
It was great, though.
JOHN WATERS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
I hate asking questions in
talks so I wrote mine down.
So I would've read
"Carsick" last night,
but it wasn't published yet, so
JOHN WATERS: Today's the date.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So, congratulations.
JOHN WATERS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And I read
"Role Models" instead.
And so you wrote about
Leslie Van Houten.
JOHN WATERS: I did.
That's kind of a
serious subject.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Well, it was really
difficult for me to--
and your next chapter is
about your sense of fashion.
It was really hard for me to go
from one chapter to the next.
But so you talk about
how she's still in jail
and she's repeatedly
denied parole.
And you make it clear that
you think it's been too long.
You even say that
JOHN WATERS: I make it clear
that Leslie Van Houten is
one of the three
original Manson women
that has been in
jail since 1969.
She looks back on it with
horror at what she did.
And has taken full
responsibility.
She is my friend.
I've visited her
for a long time.
I believe she did not
get-- her first trial,
she got the death penalty.
Her second trial,
it was overthrown.
She got a hung jury for
diminished capacity.
And the third trial she was
found guilty so she got life.
She did not get
life without parole.
She said, if I got life without
parole, I would never ask.
But she has done--
they have repeatedly
told for 40 years you're
eligible parole if you
do everything.
And she has a great record.
She's done everything.
The shrinks, everything.
And they won't let her out.
And I understand.
I don't ever
criticize the victims.
They have the
right-- I understand
why they don't think
she should get out.
But from society's
viewpoint, I do
believe that she
has paid her price.
She met a madman, one of
the most notorious madmen
of all-- she doesn't say that.
She says that she's
equally as guilty,
because you cannot have a
cult leader without followers.
I question that.
I think she was 17
when she met him.
And 1969, which is probably
the most insane year that's
gonna go down in this 1900, the
whole, you know, hundred years.
So and she does
well in prison, too.
She teaches people to read,
she does all the stuff.
AUDIENCE: Which is an excellent
summary of the chapter.
So, but--
JOHN WATERS: But
your question is--
AUDIENCE: My question is--
MALE SPEAKER 2: Yeah,
do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: I do have a question.
It seems to me that-- so, you
have this chapter in your book.
And only a number of people
are going to read that chapter.
JOHN WATERS: Well, they read
the whole book, usually.
AUDIENCE: But I mean to say
is that you would probably
make a better case you would
have a wider influence if you
were to write an
entire book about it.
And so I was surprised that
it's just in one chapter,
as opposed to its own book.
JOHN WATERS: Well, it's the
biggest chapter in the book.
I think it's 40,000
words or something.
It was run on the Huffington
but put in five different parts,
it ran.
I don't know.
My book was about people
that influenced me
for surviving things,
including Johnny Mathis.
You know, surviving great
success early and still having
a great life.
Leslie having this terrible
thing that she did and how
do you live with that?
So it was all the people
that really affected me.
So I didn't want to write
a book just about that.
I wanted to-- yes, and the
next chapter is about fashion.
Then there's a chapter
about Marine porn.
It's very different
worlds to me.
But they all are
brave in a weird way.
They survived something.
And I've always
liked people that
have had more extreme
lives than I've had,
it's always interesting to me.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
JOHN WATERS: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Does anyone
have a "Hairspray" question?
AUDIENCE: Where did you
discover Edith Massey?
JOHN WATERS: In a bar
called Pete's Hotel
that you can see in
"Multiple Maniacs"
if you can ever find a copy.
That's where she worked.
She was a bar maid.
And Vincent Peranio
and Susan Lowe
who were great friends that
were in my early movies
introduced me to her.
And there is a chapter-- I
don't want to give anything
away-- very much about her
in the new book, "Carsick."
AUDIENCE: Just as a side, I also
know a guy who did Marine porn.
JOHN WATERS: Who did what?
AUDIENCE: Marine porn.
JOHN WATERS: Oh.
Was it Bobby?
The one I wrote-- OK.
Well, I only know Bobby.
But I don't know
where he is today.
He's underground
so, I don't know.
But I did get dropped
off hitchhiking
in some military community.
I thought, maybe he's
here, I could see him.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Oh, I thought
you meant, like, sea life.
[LAUGHTER]
I swear.
I really thought
that was-- You're
talking about armed
forces military?
JOHN WATERS: Talking
about "see food."
MALE SPEAKER 2: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Actually, I
did want to ask you,
what do you think
happened to hitchhiking?
When I was a kid, I remember
my parents picking up people.
And when I was in high
school and college,
and even through my mid-20's,
that's how people got around.
JOHN WATERS: I think
"Texas Chainsaw Massacre,"
that hitchhiker had
a lot to do with it.
And "The Hitcher"
and serial killers
and the fact that there are
serial killer truckers that
have picked up women
and killed them.
So I think it just got to become
a cliche of danger, really.
AUDIENCE: So I
suppose, in a way we're
doing stuff like that
with things like rideshare
and Airbnb and things
like that sort of
gives it a cloak of safety.
JOHN WATERS: Maybe, yeah.
But also, isn't
hitchhiking green?
AUDIENCE: I would think so.
JOHN WATERS: Yeah,
it is, certainly.
It's beyond carpooling.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Absolutely.
So, thanks.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Thanks
for the question.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Now
somebody's going
make the Airbnb horror
movie and ruin that.
MALE SPEAKER 2: The
Craigslist killer.
I think he was waiting,
back there-- Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
My favorite line from all movies
is from one of your movies.
JOHN WATERS: Well, thank you.
Which one?
AUDIENCE: It's from
"Female Trouble."
The line is, "I wouldn't
suck your lousy dick
if I was suffocating and there
was oxygen in your balls."
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN WATERS: That's
not a bad line.
I like the one in
"Desperate Living"
when he says, "I'd like to stick
my whole head in your mouth
and have you suck
out my eyeballs."
AUDIENCE: That's a good one.
JOHN WATERS: Both are romantic.
AUDIENCE: But I
wanted to ask you
what is your favorite
line from movies?
JOHN WATERS: Oh, I don't know.
Because, you know, there's
a whole chapter in here
where somebody I pick up and
they refuse to talk to me
except for lines
from my movies which
drives me crazy in the book.
That happened to me once,
I really exaggerated it,
but-- The most obscure line is
when Mink asks David Lochary
something, and he just
says, "N," which means no.
That's my favorite line.
And we use it around my office
all the time-- N, we say it.
AUDIENCE: I thought
of you the other day
because I was watching "The
Prodigal" with Lana Turner
and I know you're a
big Lana Turner fan.
Did you ever--
JOHN WATERS: Well,
I'm even more a fan
of her daughter, Cheryl
Crane, who is my friend.
AUDIENCE: Did you
ever see this one?
JOHN WATERS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Oh, you know it.
JOHN WATERS: But so
long ago, I don't
know what, I don't
know each line.
AUDIENCE: No, but I
mean, it's hilarious
how it's ancient Judea
and she walks around
in high heels and a
slit skirt, you know.
JOHN WATERS: Lana was great.
I met her at a Thanksgiving
dinner with Lana Turner once,
with Cheryl and her girlfriend,
and it was quite a night.
AUDIENCE: Well thanks.
JOHN WATERS: All right, see ya.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was just
wondering what inspired you
for the character
names [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN WATERS: The character
names, I love to name them.
I have to think up their names.
Like Ready Whip, well you'll
see why I named him that one.
Lucas-- I like names.
I like Tarantula's
somebody's baby's name in it.
Randy Packard, that's
the one who kills me.
So I don't know.
I have to have their name first.
And I have this one baby
book from the 50's names,
that I've used for-- I've
almost used every one of them.
There's little checks by,
you can see all the names.
I used to have about
five or six of them.
But there's one i like best, and
it's an old Dell book that was
$0.25 "Name Your
Baby," from the 50's.
That's where I
get a lot of them.
And the last name, I just
hear them or i meet somebody,
and I don't know.
And the lawyers
always go through
and make sure there's
nobody with both names,
first and last, in your city
at that point in movies.
AUDIENCE: With
like, "Hairspray,"
most of their names are
like the first and last
are the same letter.
JOHN WATERS: Well, I had that
alliteration, yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, Tracy Turnblad.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
JOHN WATERS: Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Anyone else?
No?
So, you seem to be very
fascinated by crime, just
in general.
JOHN WATERS: Well, yes, I
mean I taught in prison.
I would be a good
defense lawyer.
But I've changed on some of it.
I apologized that for
"Role Models," and kind
of dedicating "Pink Flamingos"
to the Manson Family,
and stuff.
And I realized later
that that was really
unfeeling to the victims.
So I did change after I taught
in prison for a long time.
I don't have a favorite crime.
I'm not for it.
But I must admit,
today I read this story
that broke about these two
girls on the internet that
killed their girlfriend
believing that some fantasy
they were going to go to.
And they're 12 years old.
And they thought that they were
going to live with this wizard
somewhere.
It's an amazing story.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Has there ever
been any-- [LAUGHS]
JOHN WATERS: Well, to me it is.
MALE SPEAKER 1: No,
I didn't read it.
JOHN WATERS: I
need feel bad news.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Have
you had any kind
of rough interactions
with criminals?
And have you ever--
JOHN WATERS: No.
What do you mean, rough?
MALE SPEAKER 1: Oh I don't know.
JOHN WATERS: No, I get
along with them, usually.
MALE SPEAKER 1: All right.
JOHN WATERS: I mean, some.
I pick and choose.
MALE SPEAKER 1: There's
a part in the book where
you talk about,
possibly, well, it's
kind of as a throwaway
line of the next book maybe
being you retrying all
the drugs that you--
JOHN WATERS: Yeah, I don't
think I'm going to do that.
I said, try every drug
I ever took, in order.
But some of them-- do I
really want LSD at 68?
I don't know.
I think I've had
enough inner journeys.
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER 1: I
think I just want
to ask one last thing before
we-- if anybody wants a book,
they're did you know about that?
OK.
MALE SPEAKER 2: The books,
there's a few more for sale.
I know a bunch of you
have bought them already.
There's a few more.
I think there's actually
four for sale back there.
[WHISPERS] I'm pushing them.
JOHN WATERS: Very good.
And I'll sign them if you want.
MALE SPEAKER 2: And yeah,
he'll be here to sign.
But we can take another-- do
you have another question?
MALE SPEAKER 1:
Oh, I just wanted
to talk to you about
the tone of your films
seem to be very consistent.
And I always wonder, you
know, we make videos.
We make comedy videos.
How do you get
people to, sort of--
is there a John
Waters acting school?
JOHN WATERS: Well,
it used to be,
shout it as loud as you can.
It was like Sensaround.
But today, I think I go for a
very different kind of style.
Always the main thing I said
is, we're making a comedy.
Don't wink at the audience.
Say it like you believe every
line is completely true.
That's why I, except
for Tracy Ullman,
I almost never hired
comedians to play the part.
Because I don't want them
winking at the audience.
So, It's the same.
The tone in my book is the same.
In "Carsick," I want to just be
like, I'm telling you stories.
And I think it comes
across like that.
The tone I always want is, this
is my world, and come in it.
And I think you'll be
safe if I'm your guide.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Well, I noticed
like you worked with Johnny
Knoxville, and for some
reason I don't know why,
but that just seems right.
He just seems like somebody
who'd be right for--
JOHN WATERS: If Divine hadn't
eaten dog shit, he would've.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER 1:
Yeah, I mean, there's
some obvious reasons for that.
But there's people like
Kathleen Turner, where
you're like, yeah, I get it.
What makes a great John
Waters leading man or woman?
JOHN WATERS: Well, that
they have a sense of humor.
They don't use the word
"journey" or "craft" too much.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Well,
thanks for taking us
on this journey
about your craft.
[LAUGHTER]
And if we want to, I think,
should we do books, now?
JOHN WATERS: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
John's going to be up
here to sign some books
and you can chat with him.
How about a round of applause
for John Waters, everybody?
[APPLAUSE]